did you see the Logan Paul kar yes I
fight did you see it yeah okay I won uh
he didn't though he went off a
technicality of shitty judging but Logan
Paul that but how'd they look I mean
they look especially for not being
fighters and really only having one
amateur fight pretty [ __ ] good
especially Logan Paul athletic up you
know to be composed and stick behind a
jab for the first three rounds to where
the guy alec assem attacks like dude
that's not easy to do especially selling
out Staples Center not really well you
know so many tickets as they did be on
that huge platform to be able to stay
calm and relaxed to stick behind a jab
for three rounds you know impressive
that is with all that pressure on you
and I just think they kind of [ __ ] up
because they made they put two legit
legit fights on before I don't I don't
know why you just went to a hold YouTube
why cuz because they do comparing it or
something and no I just I feel like it's
just I know they want a crossover of
Billy Joe Billy Joe Saunders are [ __ ] I
missed that yeah Billy Joel he went yeah
he didn't look great but he got there
done and then Devin Haney's that you
know the Wow
the youngest biggest brightest star yeah
coming up so it just I think that was I
would have done that if I were them I
would have done more of a more of a
youtuber undercard hmm they fought at
eight 188 cruiserweight huh
today I did I would imagine Logan Paul
had to suck down to 188 if that's what
the cruiserweight is no close your eyes
thing damn there yeah I couldn't ask
cast I was like you guys are just
getting he is no it's over I'm not I'm
good I'm not I don't wanna be a box I
don't know that's a lot of training
cruiserweight is 200 pounds okay it was
interesting I don't think it gets a lot
of hate but it's like you know crazy ass
for two youtubers to III couldn't help
but thinking about Canelo fighting a
Andre award coming out of her
I wonder if that'll ever happen I wonder
if I was thinking about it I don't think
so yeah he said no he said no yeah I
know yeah yeah I don't get why people
really give I think the reason people
got says because they put on these like
legit world champion boxers on this main
card they're just done all YouTube then
no one really has you can't really give
anyone [ __ ] for it right and also it's
not like the zones a legit boxing
Network they're gonna be their brand the
brand new but they have no legacy
there's no history there so who gives a
[ __ ] yeah you legit promoter and you
know I'll get my people care it's pretty
impressive these two youtubers they
could have done anything they could have
think you've done brain the heart for
super are legit trainers one train with
Floyd Mayweather's uncle oh really
God Roger Mayweather yeah entire camps
what who was who was in what was that
case IRS that it's case I and then Logan
Paul had the world champion oh let's go
champ
let's go champ Oh Berbick Trevor Berbick
never asked Christ
Shannon brain freeze yeah yeah sham
breaks Tony Jeffries help them out Wow
legit cans huh yeah yeah look like
straight legit camp nother thing is they
did like countdowns for it best
countdowns you've ever seen for leaning
into a fight yeah that's what they do
right there youtubers so the the cut
downs that they did build up this fight
I think they're both like 24 something I
mean if you're gonna do it you may as
well do it at that age why not at least
you can say you did it cuz that's a big
risk
that's a [ __ ] that's what I'm saying
like you gotta give him a little respect
cuz they get it knocked out and these
two could have done anything they could
have done who's they could sprint the
climb mountains they need some jump out
of play whatever it is now we're good
yeah they decide to box yeah which is
pretty [ __ ] because they get along
and in real life er today they have this
odd they were actually hated each other
but you could even see afterwards guess
I was like because Logan's I came in I
know I talk a lot of [ __ ] you know I
hope we're cool shiny built the fight
the system personal [ __ ] he's
see that casa que si guy was kind of
like mm he's like all right that's over
man
they were cool banging out boys made
some money I bet they did
boys made some money they did big boy
money too by far the highest paid on
that card well obviously though that's
the only reason everybody was there to
see this thing
it's impressive man yeah it opens up a
weird kind of portal now now you know
Eddie Hearns like I've been hit up by
all sorts of youtubers and celebrities
who want to do the same thing yeah you
do it just don't put on just don't have
the other legit fights underneath it
mm-hm I think that's where it gets dicey
like you're mixing the two worlds great
and these guys took it seriously too so
it was super I was in pretty close to
professional yeah good amateurs or no I
mean compared to why amazed or what the
answer seemed like Golden Gloves nah
that's stupid a different game yeah it's
silly yeah pretty impressive what they
did though yeah I don't but I don't feel
like it's gonna start too much of a
drink is I don't think too many
youtubers want to Bob now dude cuz you
get hit once what happens is you start
training and you can't punch like a
sight that case I even up or Sobers you
up you see a you know the fight he's a
sturdy kid that gets all uppercut
[ __ ] wrong yeah really dude
uh are there any highlights before I
can't watch we probably can't plan but
there's definitely highlights Rock them
really oh dude Wow Logan Paul got rock
do you got that down as well Jesus he
did mm-hmm
you know see this real quick yeah okay
so that guy just kept coming he looks so
tired too he knocks it down there him
yeah the uppercut was vicious and this
is where our Logan's at [ __ ] [ __ ]
row one
DOJ's uppercut before but he had he
grabbed him by the head there I know but
the uppercut before it look at this Oh
Oh legit this is rage every last two
points we grab the head you gotta be in
shape you gotta be in [ __ ] that's
crazy this looks like a bra that
uppercut was the best shot of the night
he just [ __ ] up cuz he gret he rocked
them and then grabbed that head and rock
did you tell me Logan wrestled in
college or in high school he's a big
strong that's a bold move
that's a beautiful move this is the the
grabbing and stuff like that that's just
lack of experience how bad is that when
they do it if even it's just like
brushing across them but he did it's
just lack of experience he's not like
it's this the only very tough to do that
he's never looked very good that that
slip and upper cut is so hard to pull
off I mean that that itself is a big
accomplishment it's [ __ ] hard it's
really hard to box this way
look at him slip yeah look at him slip
he's a crab yeah I didn't know that the
problem is like this he didn't need a
grab that dude was very [ __ ] up on
that uppercut wow there's a tough [ __ ]
though if he would have just not grabbed
his head you know and that but that's
how Logan Paul because they this wrath
was ridiculous super outlandish the rest
of you did that shot points hmm
which is unheard of didn't warn
especially these guys being their first
pro fight no warnings just take two
points away they're both sturdy
rough-looking his man I mean they're
guys I mean these are strong as [ __ ] I
mean big yeah hey look good the rough
was terrible though they're a few took
forever to break them up to the rest
slow walking too long I don't know what
was going on that ref the ref made about
himself yeah disappointing worst case we
don't take the points let's say you take
one point or a warning then it'd be
another draw yeah that was rough looking
those are that was the first one yeah
yeah it was interesting is the
interesting is entertaining as a way
better than I thought yeah like I was
like hey let's go the other fights the
disappered
ozone was bad where they're swinging I
mean yeah I think one mistake you're
going to sleep there's [ __ ] guys like
that hit hard
yes impressed released a decided to do
that because again they could have got
however many views this I don't know
what the papery numbers are but how many
views they got they could have done that
doing playing chess these guys yeah they
could done anything and they're both
done with it I don't know if Logan is
but Logan wants it back but that guy
said he's done yes Logan wants to fight
again because he feels like it was taken
from him the two points was pretty
freakin crazy
yeah I'm sure they're both pretty
concussed after that fight looks like oh
yeah
they're not gonna be like a hundred
percent healthy for sure they're young
yeah yeah worth it great yeah I want to
say I heard you didn't make ten million
dollars I think it was more Justin
Bieber was in the entourage just off off
the top I heard both made ten and ten
did they give us fight person numbers
possibly know what you're saying what
the Commission pays them yeah papers
were there making their money yeah how
much does it say Billy Joe Saunders 750
y'all getting read how much should is he
here I think that's it alright our
silikal service you should grow up this
way or the other way oh there's Oh Devin
Haney made a million dollars that's nice
that's a lot you know boys making money
baby I'm curious to see how many people
bought it yeah I think disowns making a
little bit of a mistake where they think
there's gonna be a crossovers because
the reason they did they want
subscribers to the zone right but that
young fanbase didn't you [ __ ] I
subscribe to the zone though just
because I they had the Canelo fight and
that yes sir not what I'm talking about
so yeah so the reason why they did Logan
Paul Kerr thighs because they thought
the young kids would bring my
subscribers yeah I think they're off on
it
those kids are just gonna do that
get out they're not into by the design
Scott must have so much money though
because there's just
they'd they're getting they're
guaranteeing these fires so much money I
thought they stopped they started to
pull back yeah yeah they have to do it
originally you know to get all the big
names yeah lookin Paul's a unique guy
felt like a brick [ __ ] big boy oh
yeah oh yeah I don't really know him but
none um none of my friends really
watched it this no no I don't know any
anyone like you might crew what they
don't watch it
I'm gonna watch it yeah I'm gonna so
taking my training more seriously and
tell you this right now yeah yeah yeah
yeah watch your tongue Oh what's gonna
happen what are you gonna do use some of
that boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]